جهاز استشعار يكشف عن مستويات منخفضة بشكل خطير
من الأكسجين
الذي خنقه فيروس كورونا ، تشتري علبة الغاز
هذه وقت المريض الذي وصل فيه
كل هؤلاء المرضى بالكاد
قادرين على التنفس ،
هذه ليست عيادة طبية ، إنها خيمة
في ضواحي عاصمة الهند
يديرها متطوعون بدون مبادرة
أظهر هؤلاء المتطوعون من
مؤسسة Hemkund
الذين يقدمون الأكسجين في الشارع
على مشارف دلهي ، ويقولون إن
العشرات ربما
أكثر من مائة مريض سيكونون في
ورطة طبية كبيرة الآن لديهم بالفعل
حالة وفاة واحدة
هناك في وقت سابق اليوم.
لقد عالجنا أكثر من مائة شخص
جاؤوا في
أمس الحاجة إلى أكسجين غير قادرين على التنفس
، وكل هذا
يتعلق بتزويد أسطوانات الأكسجين هذه
، كل مسافة 300 ميل في كل
اتجاه للحصول على واحدة من هذه الأسطوانات وإعادتها إلى
دلهي ، تكلفتها حوالي 25  عندما تملأ ، ما مدى
سهولة العثور على الأكسجين ، يا إلهي
صدقني ، كان هذا أصعب
شيء نواجهه
مع 19 إصابة خفية وخدر  عدد
الوفيات التي تحطم الأرقام القياسية يوميًا في الهند ،
تخلى العديد من المرضى في دلهي عن
العلاج بالمستشفى
حيث يعلمون أن الأكسجين نادر
وأن الأسرة
غالبًا ما تشترك في بانكاج ، وقال تشانديويل إنه
تم إبعاده من قبل ثلاثة مستشفيات
قام بخلع قناع الأكسجين الخاص به طالبًا
أن يسمع صوته
ولكن  إنهم لا يستمتعون
بأي
شيء وهم يرفضون فقط كل الأشياء التي
لا يمكنني إخبارها لمن يمكنني إلقاء اللوم
عليها ، فهي
الحكومة والمستشفيات أيضًا يتم إنتاج الأكسجين المعبأ في
الغالب
خارج دلهي والدول المجاورة
تعطي الأولوية لاحتياجاتها الخاصة
، وبالتالي تلهث المدينة  ويموت
الكثيرون في
منازلهم دون تسجيل جثث المرضى الذين يموتون في
المنزل ، وسوف يلتقط ثلاثة منهم
في هذه الرحلة التي تستغرق ساعة واحدة ،
ويخشى الكثيرون من نقل أحبائهم المحتضرين
إلى المستشفى
[موسيقى]
قررت عائلة براشانت شارما الاحتفاظ
بجدته  في المنزل
[تصفيق]
كنا خائفين من رؤية الحالة من
حولنا ،
لذلك شعرنا بالخوف إذا أخذناها إلى أي
مستشفى قريب سيذهب إليك ويعلم أن يكون على
اتصال  هي التي ستزودنا
بالمعلومات بالضبط ما يجري داخل
المستشفى
، وعدت حكومة الهند
بحملة تطعيم
بقوة متجددة ولكن مع
تلقيح حوالي 2٪ فقط من الأمة حتى
الآن ، هذا راحة باردة هنا
sam kiley cnn delhi